joining me now for more reaction to all
of this former US attorney Brett Holman
and Florida congressman Matt gage I mean
there's already a criminal referral
against against Nellie or
there probably should be one in my
judgment against Bruce or but we'll wait
and see I want to tackle another subject
with you congressman gates we now learn
you can read about other Daily Caller
that according to a Senate report every
single Hillary Clinton email was sent
secretly to a cryptic gmail address
including classified documents so you've
got potentially hundreds if not
thousands of documents that are
sensitive if not classified they can
easily be hacked on a Google server and
an intelligent agent discovered it
notified Peter struck who was quote
disinterested and dismissive congressman
how can that be the reason this is the
case is because they all thought Hillary
Clinton was going to win remember Greg
the Trump Russia allegations weren't the
crime they were the cover-up because a
lot of these folks at the FBI and
Department of Justice thought that they
would be retaliated against by a future
president Hillary Clinton if they
aggressively pursued the facts and
applied the law when it related to hunt
unlawful conduct with emails and a
sensitive and classified information so
the reason we're getting this drip by
drip is because you had people the FBI
and Department of Justice who were
paving a yellow brick road to
exoneration for Hillary Clinton when
they should have been doing their job
and that's because James Comey curated
an environment at the FBI where they
weren't really doing investigations they
were trying to shape public opinion and
when you see the bias that was so
evident in the case of the people
investigating Hillary Clinton there's no
excuse for the outcome that she wasn't
forced to to account for that bad
conduct I you know if you classified
documents on a Google server Brett I
mean everybody's got it including the
Russians and and we now also know that
the Chinese apparently hacked Hillary
Clinton's classified documents and
once again the FBI is notified of this
and they didn't care isn't that just the
quintessential malfeasance of the FBI
well I know a hundred agents and
executives of the FBI that would have
reacted differently then Peter struck
did and it would have been you know
place this at the top of their priority
list bottom line on on classified
information think about this Greg taking
any classified information and miss
handling it to summarize what our laws
state miss handling of classified
information is a crime in this country
you know perhaps the only the only one
that's a bit relieved tonight is Hillary
Clinton because the story doesn't seem
to to come back to focus on the fact
that she has a private server and these
emails are on a private server and those
emails end up going to a more public
place by her instruction you have to you
have to believe it's by her instruction
she hired the company and they put it on
that to that public place for anyone to
potentially see it and let's face it
right now and back then China is
absolutely one of our top threats to
this country's national security
Paul combate is the IT guy work for
Hillary Clinton and unbelievably
congressman he got immunity from the FBI
in exchange for nothing which in my
almost 40 years as a lawyer I've never
heard of that never seen that before he
gets immunity from prosecution and now
he's refusing to even cooperate or talk
to the DOJ inspector general well when
we in the Congress saw the immunity
deals that were given not only in this
instance but to a variety of other
Hillary Clinton associates you wonder
what was really bargained for an
immunity deal is in exchange for
evidence that leads to a more
high-profile or high-priority target
that the government has in a particular
case but you saw blanket immunity deals
given to people that didn't create more
of an
Senath for them to give information it
created less of an incentive as you're
seeing right now and I think that that
it was really drawn into critique by the
inspector general when he analyzed the
bias that existed here and really the
extent to which that bias could have
impacted the outcome in the case and
Brett I'll let you have the last word
I've only got about 30 seconds left but
this is as crooked as the day is long
isn't it well it is in 20 years of
practicing federal criminal law I I was
never able to get blanket immunity not
for a cooperator that I was I wanted DOJ
to give immunity not for when I became a
defense attorney not for any of my
clients they got limited immunity and
they always had to give something up
that was substantial what we have here
is is failure that starting to percolate
up at multiple levels and and it's just
the beginning
yeah well this was James commis FBI the
sanctimonious vainglorious former FBI
director gentlemen thank you very much
for being with us
congressman gates Brett Tolan thank you
so much